ايضا مشاهدينا في اوكرانيا والجبهه
الشرقيه والتطورات الميدانيه هناك ما تزال
القوات الروسيه تسعى جاهده للسيطره على
كامل دونياتك لاحكام سيطرتها على كامل
اقليم نشرح قليلا هذه التطورات الميدانيه
مشاهدينا من خلال هذه الشاشه التفاعليه
اذا مشاهدينا نبدا في المتابعه اذا هنا في
شرق اوكرانيا ما الذي حصل اليوم التطورات
اللافته هنا في باقمت دعونا نذهب اليها
اذا هنا اذا مشاهدينا كثافه القوات
الروسيه بمسانده مجموعه هجماتها على
الجبهه الشرقيه وكذلك الشماليه
والجنوبيه كذلك في محاوله للسيطره على
كامل ضخمه وهي بذلك استخدمت اذن الجنود في
محاوله لحصار باخمت بشكل كامل على هذه
المدينه القوات الاوكرانيه لم تصمت هي
تحاول استخدام مجموعه من الدعم العسكري من
هنا من هذه المدينه مدينه شاذوف يار وهذا
عن طريق استخدام جنود كذلك ومجموعه كذلك
من الدبابات من اجل صد هجوم قوات فاجنر
والقوات الروسيه التي تحاول السيطره على
اذا هذا في ضخمه نذهب الى جبله جبهه اخرى
مشتعله اليوم هنا في الجنوب نتحدث عن شبه
جزيره القرم التي ضمتها روسيا وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه قالت ان اوكرانيا جنت
اليوم هجوما كبيرا بطائرات مسيره
اذا هذه هي الطائرات المسيره حوالي عشر
طائرات مسيره نفذت هجمات مختلفه على مناطق
القرم وتمكنت القوات الروسيه من صد هذه
الهجمات واضافت انه لا اضرار او خسائر
كذلك في هذه الهجمات اذا التي شنتها
القوات الاوكرانيه باستخدام المسيرات